[Music]
Drake is keeping fans on their toes this
week with this fake rollout it All Began
earlier this week with the Photoshop
Vogue coverage to promote his upcoming
collab album with 21 Savage titled her
loss
side not the middle row
all good love in a minute though the
Toronto rapper posted the covered
Instagram and captioned it me and my
brother on newsstands tomorrow thanks
Vogue magazine and Aunt Wintour for the
love and support on this historic moment
her loss November 4th up next CT said he
would be teaming up with 21 Savage for a
special tiny desk performance what's up
everybody appreciate you uh joining us
today all the audience everybody at home
my name is Drake 21 Savage and uh this
is our tiny desk let's get it yeah let's
get into it all right this fake version
caught the attention of everybody
including tiny desk Creator Bob Boylan
who invited Drake to actually do a real
performance on the show then he shared a
fake interview with radio host Howard
Stern captioning it absolutely no filter
with the incomparable Stern Show thanks
for having us What About Love
I mean could you ever commit to one
woman yeah yeah yeah be married you
could be married
I'm sure I could you know like I think
uh
I think that I think that eventually
once all this is said and done for us
and that addiction of work and success
and forward movement is over I feel like
we're all gonna need something real
Drake's album her loss arrives this
Friday we hope we hope he wouldn't fake
that out right
[Music]